pour montrer à leurs petits comment faire, ce qui s'appelle enseigner.
Les chimpanzés n'enseignent pas.
Les orques enseignent et ils partagent leur nourriture.
Quand l'évolution produit de la nouveauté,
elle utilise les éléments qu'elle a en stock, hors de ses tiroirs,
avant de produire un nouveau tournant.
Et notre cerveau nous est parvenu
à travers l'immensité temporelle de l'histoire.
Si vous comparez le cerveau humain à celui d'un chimpanzé,
vous constatez que nous avons en fait un très gros cerveau de chimpanzé.
C'est bien que le nôtre soit plus gros car nous avons très peu confiance en nous.
(Rires)
Mais, attention, il y a un dauphin,
un cerveau plus gros avec plus de convolutions.
Peut-être pensez-vous, d'accord, on voit des cerveaux,
mais qu'est-ce que ça dit sur l'esprit ?
On peut voir le travail de l'esprit
dans la logique des comportements.
Ces éléphants, vous pouvez le voir,
ont l'air de se reposer.
Ils ont trouvé un peu d'ombre sous les palmiers,
sous lesquels ils peuvent laisser leurs bébés dormir,
pendant qu'ils sommeillent mais restent vigilants.
Nous comprenons parfaitement cette image
tout comme ils comprennent parfaitement ce qu'ils font,
parce que sous l'arc du même soleil, dans les mêmes plaines,
à écouter les hurlements des mêmes dangers,
ils sont devenus ce qu'ils sont et nous ce que nous sommes.
Nous sommes voisins depuis très longtemps.
Personne ne ferait l'erreur de penser que ces éléphants sont détendus.
De toute évidence, quelque chose les préoccupe vraiment.
Qu'est-ce qui les préoccupe ?
Il s'avère que si vous avez un enregistrement de voix de touristes
et que vous le diffusez depuis un haut-parleur caché dans les buissons,
les éléphants l'ignorent, car les touristes ne les embêtent jamais.
Mais si vous enregistrez les voix d'éleveurs
qui portent des lances et blessent souvent les éléphants
lors de confrontations près de points d'eau,
les éléphants se regroupent et s'éloignent en courant du haut-parleur dissimulé.
Non seulement les éléphants savent que ces voix sont humaines,
mais ils savent qu'il y a différents types d'humains,
et que certains sont OK et que d'autres sont dangereux.
Ils nous observent depuis plus longtemps que nous ne les observons.
Ils nous connaissent mieux que nous ne les connaissons.
Nous avons les mêmes nécessités :
s'occuper de nos bébés, trouver à manger, essayer de rester en vie.
Que nous soyons équipés pour la randonnée dans les collines d'Afrique,
ou équipés pour la plongée sous-marine, au fond, nous sommes pareils.
Sous la peau, nous sommes parents.
L'éléphant a le même squelette,
l'orque a le même squelette
que nous.
Nous voyons de l'aide lorsqu'elle est requise.
Nous voyons de la curiosité chez les enfants.
Nous voyons les liens familiaux.
Nous reconnaissons l'affection.
La parade nuptiale est la parade nuptiale.
Puis nous demandons : « Sont-ils conscients ? »
Une anesthésie générale nous rend inconscient,
ce qui veut dire que nous ne pouvons rien sentir du tout.
La conscience est simplement la chose qui a l'air de quelque chose.
Si vous voyez, entendez, ressentez, si vous êtes conscients de quelque chose,
vous êtes conscients, et ils sont conscients.
Des gens disent que certaines choses font que les humains sont humains,
et l'une de ces choses est l'empathie.
L'empathie est la capacité de l'esprit
à assortir vos humeurs à celles de vos compagnons.
C'est très utile.
Si vos compagnons se mettent à marcher rapidement,
vous devez sentir qu'il faut vous presser.
Nous sommes maintenant tous pressés.
La plus vieille forme d'empathie est la peur contagieuse.
Si vos compagnons sursautent soudainement et s'envolent,
il n'est pas bon pour vous de dire :
« Dis donc, je me demande pourquoi tout le monde est parti. »
(Rires)
L'empathie est vieille, mais l'empathie, comme tout dans la vie,
vient sur une échelle variable et a ses élaborations.
Il y a l'empathie de base : vous êtes triste, ça me rend triste.
Je vous vois heureux, ça me rend heureux.
Puis il y a quelque chose que j'appelle la sympathie,
un peu plus différent :
« Je suis désolé d'apprendre que votre grand-mère vient de s'éteindre.
Je ne ressens pas la même peine, mais je comprends ;
je sais ce que vous ressentez et ça me préoccupe. »
Si vous êtes ensuite motivés d'agir sur cette sympathie,
j'appelle ça de la compassion.
Loin d'être ce qui nous rend humain,
l'empathie humaine est loin d'être parfaite.
Nous rassemblons des créatures empathiques,
nous les tuons et nous les mangeons.
Peut-être dites-vous, ce sont des espèces différentes.
Ce n'est que la prédation, et les humains sont des prédateurs.
Mais nous ne traitons pas très bien les nôtres également.
Ceux qui ne savent qu'une seule chose sur les animaux
savent que l'on ne doit jamais attribuer les pensées et émotions humaines
aux autres espèces.
Je trouve que c'est bête,
parce qu'attribuer les pensées et émotions humaines aux autres espèces
est la meilleure première supposition sur leurs activités et leurs sentiments,
parce que leurs cerveaux sont au final les mêmes que le nôtre.
Ils ont les mêmes structures.
Les mêmes hormones qui, chez nous, créent les humeurs et la motivation
se trouvent aussi dans ces cerveaux.
Ce n'est pas scientifique de dire qu'ils ont faim lorsqu'ils chassent,
qu'ils sont fatigués lorsque leur langue pend,
puis dire lorsqu'ils jouent avec leurs enfants,
plein de joie et heureux,
que nous n'avons aucune idée s'ils peuvent possiblement ressentir quoi que ce soit.
Ce n'est pas scientifique.
Un journaliste m'a dit :
« Peut-être, mais comment savez-vous vraiment
que les animaux peuvent penser et ressentir ? »
Et j'ai commencé à parcourir les centaines
de références scientifiques dans mon livre
et j'ai réalisé que la réponse se trouvait dans cette pièce même.
Lorsque ma chienne se lève du tapis et vient me voir —
pas le canapé, moi —
et qu'elle se met sur le dos et me montre son ventre,
elle a pensé : « J'ai envie qu'on me caresse le ventre.
Je sais que je peux aller voir Carl,
il comprendra ce que je lui demande.
Je sais que je peux lui faire confiance parce qu'on est une famille.
Il va faire ce qu'il faut, et ça sera bien. »
(Rires)
Elle a pensé et elle a senti,
et ce n'est vraiment pas plus compliqué que ça.
Mais nous voyons d'autres animaux et nous disons :
« Regardez, les orques, les loups, les éléphants,
on ne les voit pas de cette façon. »
Ce mâle à l'aileron fin est L41.
Il a 38 ans.
La femelle à sa gauche est L22.
Elle a 44 ans.
Ils se connaissent depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années.
Ils savent parfaitement qui ils sont.
Ils savent qui sont leurs amis.
Ils savent qui sont leurs rivaux.
Leur vie suit la courbe d'une carrière.
Ils savent tout le temps où ils sont.
Voici un éléphant qui s'appelle Philo.
C'était un jeune mâle.
Le voici quatre jours plus tard.
Non seulement les humains sentent la peine, mais ils en créent des tonnes.
Nous voulons tailler leurs dents.
Pourquoi n'attendons-nous pas qu'ils meurent ?
Autrefois, on trouvait des éléphants des côtes de la mer Méditerranée
jusqu'au Cap de Bonne-Espérance.
En 1980, il y avait de vastes fiefs de répartition d'éléphants
en Afrique Centrale et en Afrique de l'Est.
Désormais, ils sont répartis en petits groupes.
C'est la géographie d'un animal que nous menons à l'extinction,
un semblable, la créature la plus splendide sur terre.
Bien sûr, nous nous occupons bien mieux de notre faune aux États-Unis.
Dans le parc national de Yellowstone, nous avons tué tous les loups.
Nous avons tué tous les loups au sud de la frontière canadienne.
Mais dans le parc, les gardes forestiers ont fait ça dans les années 20.
Puis 60 ans plus tard, il a fallu les ramener,
parce que le nombre d'élans était devenu trop important.
Puis les gens sont venus.
Les gens sont venus par milliers pour voir les loups,
les loups les plus visibles et accessibles au monde.
J'y suis allé et j'ai observé cette incroyable famille de loups.
Une meute est une famille.
Une meute a des adultes reproducteurs et les petits de plusieurs générations.
J'ai observé la meute la plus célèbre, la plus stable
du parc national de Yellowstone.
Puis, lorsqu'ils se sont aventurés juste hors de la frontière,
deux de leurs adultes furent tués,
y compris la mère,
que nous appelons parfois la femelle alpha.
Le reste de la famille est immédiatement tombé dans une rivalité fraternelle.
Des sœurs ont expulsé d'autres sœurs.
Celle de gauche a essayé de réintégrer sa famille pendant des jours.
Ses sœurs l'en ont empêchée car elles étaient jalouses.
Deux nouveaux mâles lui témoignaient beaucoup trop d'attention,
et elle était précoce.
C'en était trop pour ses sœurs.
Elle s'est retrouvée à errer hors du parc et à se faire tuer.
Le mâle alpha se retrouva expulsé de sa propre famille.
Alors que l'hiver approchait,
il perdit son territoire, son groupe de chasse,
les membres de sa famille et ses amis.
Nous leur faisons tellement de mal.
Le mystère est : pourquoi ne nous font-ils pas plus de mal ?
Cet orque venait de terminer de manger un morceau d'une baleine grise
avec ses compagnons qui avaient tué cette baleine.
Les gens sur ce bateau n'avaient absolument rien à craindre.
Cet orque est T20.
Il venait juste de finir de déchiqueter un phoque en trois avec deux compagnons.
Le phoque pesait à peu près autant que les gens sur le bateau.
Ils n'avaient rien à craindre.
Ils mangent des phoques.
Pourquoi ne nous mangent-ils pas ?
Pourquoi pouvons-nous leur faire confiance avec nos nourrissons ?
Pourquoi les orques sont-ils revenus vers des chercheurs perdus dans le brouillard
et les ont guidés jusqu'à ce que le brouillard disparaisse,
et que la maison des chercheurs se trouve devant eux, sur la côte.
Et c'est arrivé plus d'une fois.
Aux Bahamas, une femme du nom de Denise Herzing
étudie les dauphins tachetés et ils la connaissent.
Elle les connaît très bien. Elle connaît chacun d'entre eux.
Ils la connaissent. Ils reconnaissent son bateau.
Les retrouvailles sont toujours joyeuses.
Hormis une fois, où les dauphins ne voulaient pas s'approcher du bateau,
et c'était très étrange.
Ils ne comprenaient pas pourquoi, jusqu'à ce que qu'on vienne leur dire
que l'une des personnes à bord était morte,
lors d'une sieste dans son lit.
Comment les dauphins ont-ils pu savoir que l'un des cœurs humains
venait juste de s'arrêter ?
Pourquoi s'en préoccuperaient-ils ?
Et pourquoi en seraient-ils effrayés ?
Ces événements mystérieux font allusion à tout ce qui se passe
dans les esprits qui sont avec nous, sur Terre,
et auxquels nous ne pensons presque jamais.
Dans un aquarium d'Afrique du Sud
se trouvait un petit bébé dauphin qui s'appelait Dolly.
Elle tétait, et un jour, un gardien prit une pause cigarette,
et il regardait dans leur bassin par la fenêtre, en fumant.
Dolly nagea vers lui, le regarda,
retourna voir sa mère, téta pendant une ou deux minutes,
retourna vers la vitre,
et recracha un nuage de lait qui enveloppa sa tête comme de la fumée.
D'une façon ou d'une autre, ce bébé dauphin
eut l'idée d'utiliser le lait pour représenter la fumée.
Lorsque les humains utilise une chose pour en représenter une autre,
on appelle ça de l'art.
(Rires)
Ce qui nous rend humains
n'est pas ce que nous croyons.
Ce qui nous rend humains est que,
de toutes ces choses que nos esprits et leurs esprits ont,
nous sommes les plus extrêmes.
Nous sommes l'animal le plus compatissant,
le plus violent, le plus créatif,
et le plus destructeur que cette planète ait jamais connu.
Nous sommes toutes ces choses, toutes mélangées les unes avec les autres.
Mais l'amour n'est pas ce qui nous rend humains.
L'amour ne nous est pas spécifique.
Nous ne sommes pas les seuls à aimer nos compagnons.
Nous ne sommes pas les seuls à aimer nos enfants.
Les albatros parcourent fréquemment des dizaines de milliers de kilomètres
pendant plusieurs semaines pour livrer un repas, un gros repas,
à leurs petits qui les attendent.
Ils font leurs nids sur les îles les plus isolées des océans du monde,
et voici à quoi ça ressemble.
Transmettre la vie d'une génération à la suivante est la chaîne de la vie.
Si cette chaîne s'arrête, tout disparaît.
Si quelque chose est sacré, cette chaîne l'est,
et dans cette relation sacrée vient nos déchets plastiques.
Tous ces oiseaux ont maintenant du plastique dans leur corps.
Voici un albatros de six mois, près à prendre son envol
mort, rempli de briquets rouges.
Ce n'est pas la relation que nous sommes censés avoir
avec le reste du monde.
Mais nous, qui nous sommes nommés d'après nos cerveaux,
ne pensons jamais aux conséquences.
Lorsque nous fêtons des naissances,
nous accueillons nos bébés en compagnie d'autres créatures.
Nous peignons des animaux sur les murs.
Nous ne peignons pas des téléphones.
Nous ne peignons pas des bureaux.
Nous peignons des animaux pour leur montrer que nous ne sommes pas seuls.
Nous avons de la compagnie.
Et chacun de ces animaux dans chaque peinture de l'arche de Noé,
jugé digne d'être sauvé est désormais en danger mortel,
et nous sommes leur plaie.
Nous avons commencé par une question :
les animaux nous aiment-ils ?
Nous allons poser une autre question.
Sommes-nous capables d'utiliser ce que nous avons
pour les aimer assez afin de les laisser vivre ?
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)